salué les ventes à l'eau aujourd'hui on
va apprendre à interpréter les pensées
d'une personne sans la regarder
et pour ça je suis avec mon pote noam
bonjour on va parler aujourd'hui de cuba
c'est parfait et noam n'y connais
strictement rien en cubes et relents 10
mhz et vous non plus et c'est tout
l'intérêt que tu sois là c'est à dire
que je vais expliquer comment on fait
des choses tu vas pouvoir poser toutes
les questions que tu veux en fait aux
questions un peu naïve
les gens pourraient se pose exactement
tu as tu un peu le délégué de classe le
délégué c'est pour moi les enfants
qu'est ce que le cube berlin 10 le cul
berlin 10 c'est le muscle reding s'est
la lecture micro musculaire
l'interprétation des micromouvements
musculaire gym et un tube à se faire
puisque je veux faire c'est mieux que tu
vois en général ça se prend ici au
poignet parce qu'il ya beaucoup de mu le
petit terminaisons nerveuses de choses
qui sont reliés jusqu'aux doigts et
c'est toi qui sont eux aussi chez les
autres
oui mais là vous demandez à quoi ça sert
une très bonne question qui se sont
posées je les ai entendus attendu ben
moi aussi entendu
alors ça sert à faire des choses un peu
ouvre par exemple dans une vidéo
récemment avec nos âmes
j'ai trouvé un objet auquel il pensait
grâce à cette méthode je vous invite
tout de suite à cliquer sur la tête de
noix je fais le car est allé voir la
vidéo sort sa chaîne est comme ça vous
allez voir une application directe de ça
ensuite vous n'allez pas pouvoir vous
empêcher de regarder deux trois vidéos
de lui elles sont cool donc vous allez
vous abonner une fois que tout ça c'est
fait vous revenez ici et on voit gentil
être gentil mais je suis surtout payé
pour ça exactement soit directement à la
mairie un café
si je veux faire une étude un peu
comportementale pour voir s'ils n'en ont
pas avec l'intonation de la voix je lui
posais des questions de bâtiments qui
t'appelle tout en suisse et a commencé
sa chaîne youtube depuis combien de
temps officiellement depuis décembre
voilà et là on a vu plein de choses sur
son visage
alors qu'on sait réviser la vie la
vérité on a vu comment tu fais on sait
que quand tu cherches une réponse selon
regarde vers le haut on sait que quand
tu es un petit peu stressé et est
capable de faire ça donc ce ne serait
pas des signes du mensonge
je le sais parce que je t'ai poser des
questions de vérité j'étais calibré et
ensuite ça me permettrait par des
différents segments ou pas prêt à
croquer et b pour le cube arrondissement
c'est pareil je vais d'abord prendre
le premier de la personne et je vais
avant de poser quelques questions que ce
soit sentir un petit peu les mouvements
de base qui a en fait et en bougeant
comme savoir de savoir mon ouïe et mon
nom d'intérêts moi c'est ça qui est
création les choses qui ne sont pas
interprétés dire que la twa par exemple
tu as souvent ce muscle là qui bouge
pour rien donc si en faisant quelque
chose ils bougent se sera pas un signe
de validation en fait d'accord grave pas
dire qu'il se passe quelque chose mais
vous aussi vous avez déjà calibré
quelqu'un toi aussi tu as déjà calibre
est quelqu un dans ton entourage sans
forcément déterminé que tu faisais ça
mais il ya des personnes que tu connais
tu sais exactement la manière qu'ils ont
de parler tu sais exactement la manière
qu'ils ont de faire les choses de réagir
à des choses donc c'est comme si tu les
avais calibré ça t'a fait qu'à un jour
en fonction de ce qu'ils ne le disent
pas toi tu sais ce qui voudrait dire où
tu sais s'ils mentent par exemple ça va
c'est vraiment plus
j'ai déjà j'ai un pote à chaque fois tim
ans il se touche l'oreille mais vraiment
c'est un rappel intel au poker c'est un
vrai si le fait de savoir sa survie
c'est une calibration
bien sûr si vous aussi vous avez déjà
calibre et des gens comme vos parents
vos amis etc
dites le dans les commentaires dites
lessing qui a chez eux qui sont
révélateurs sera toujours marrant aussi
pour nous le lieu
ton papa qu'il avait les sourcils quand
ils mourront j'ai des exercices pour
vous pour vous entraîner à faire parce
que le cubain monde ici a pas trente
mille méthode à part essayer s'entraîner
ressentir soi-même deux manières de
prendre le poignet de la personne soit
la personne nous prend le poignet et là
vous allez surtout réagir sur la
résistance que ça offre soit vous prenez
le poignet de la personne comme j'ai
fait dans la vidéo c'est ce qu'il ya de
plus efficace exactement alors soit on
prend comme ça
soit on prend comme ça quand vous
commencez mettez les quatre doigts en
dessous et on sent beaucoup mieux sa
puissance et leur premier exercice
exercices très simples
vous mettez 5 6 7 8 9 10 objets sur une
table vous demandez à une personne de
penser un des objets de l'écrire sur un
papier pour vérifier après qu'elle
puisse pas changer etc
et là vous prenez la main et vous y
allez en fait sur la table et vous allez
sentir plusieurs choses vous allez
sentir une résistance en fait à certains
endroits et vous allez sentir aussi les
petits muscles qui se mettent à bouger
mais concentrez-vous sur la résistance
pour que ces réactions existe il faut
que la personne ait quelque chose à
faire de mentalement c'est ce qu'il a
déclenché la réaction
donc vous pouvez par exemple lui dire de
crier stop dans sa tête à chaque fois
que vous passez au dessus de l'objet
tu vois ok le fait qu'elle se dise top
mentalement ça va créer des petites
tensions comme ça et ça va créer une
petite résistance
la deuxième exercice qui est un peu plus
complexe mais qui est hyper intéressant
aussi
vous pouvez le faire en deux étapes
c'est tu donnes un objet à quelqu'un il
doit le cacher dans la pièce quand tu
sors la pièce de cash et après tu dois
le retrouver comme ça
ok donc tu tu prends le poignet de la
personne et puis de la même manière
comme les aveugles exactement alors au
départ le vrai truc à faire pour cet
exercice et au départ tu fais faire un
tour sur lui-même à la personne j'ai
commencé à se diriger et après tu y vas
tu peux le faire en deux temps
pas obligé de partir sur un petit objet
au départ au contraire au départ la
première fois partait sur des gros
objets des choses un peu dur à cacher
comme ça ça va limiter aussi un peu le
champ de surf
si je te donne une gomme et je te donne
une boule de bowling tu va se dire il ya
plus ou moins la trouver un pin's là
dedans voilà ce que j'avais à dire sur
le pluralisme et jeunes hommes très
intéressants en tout cas c'est très
bluffant
vous verrez en tout cas c'est assez
frustrant surtout si vous regardez the
mentalist et tout ça même si lui même le
dit on sait pas du tout ce que ça veut
dire la liste c'est pas bloquer la voir
c'est vraiment impressionnant je vous le
dis franchement c'était vraiment cet
effort en émotions parce que pour lui ça
s'est passé il ya quelques minutes à
peine voilà pour vous dire on regarde le
temps ça fait dix minutes je fais
exactement un petit rajout la juste
avant de partir j'ai oublié de vous
parler de ça pensez toujours à bien
préparer votre sujet avant de le faire
sinon c'est un risque d'échec préparer
le sujet ça veut dire parler avec lui au
départ le détendre qui se sentent pas
stressé ou qui se sentent pas la
pression à faire ça et habitués le
assume focaliser sur vocaliser s'est
parlé dans sa tête il faut qu'ils disent
stop par exemple quand vous êtes à
l'objet ou droit de gauche ou bas mais
il faut quand même qu'ils se parle à lui
même intérieurement c'est ce qui va
envoyer des micro mouvements incontrôlés
exactement c'est juste ça c'était
important de le repréciser préparer le
sujet préparé hier préparé je t'aime à
ses avants ouais exactement l'a bien
senti les tensions et tout le dos et
c'est très gênant terre très gênant vtt
gémissements
très gênant les jambes très gênant si
vous voulez voir les gémissements
demandé dans les commentaires on voulait
mettre par écrit
du coup cela écrit merci beaucoup
d'avoir regardé cette vidéo j'espère que
ce sujet là vous aura plu si vous voulez
aller un petit peu plus loin il ya un
livre qui s'appelle la magie du corps de
john fisher c'est un livre qui ces vieux
cette date de 1987 je vous mettrais un
lien si je trouve un lien dans les
commentaires mais sinon je me mettrai au
moins la référence ça c'est pour ceux
qui veulent aller plus loin mais
n'oubliez pas le cul berland 10 la seule
méthode réel pour bien l'apprendre de
maîtriser c'est d'essayer de le
pratiquer et de se tromper au départ et
c'est pas grave c'est tout à fait normal
si vous avez aimé cette vidéo n'hésitez
pas à nous faire savoir en laissant
comme ça un petit mouvement incontrôlé
et incontrôlable un pouce en l'air
n'oubliez pas de vous abonner à la
chaîne avant de partir et rendez vous
demain à 17h ciao bye
ok